Up to this point we've covered four different conic sections. We looked at
circles then ellipses, hyperbola and finally parabola. We call each of these a
conic section because they come from the intersection of a plane with a cone.
So, here we have a cone and we have a plane that intersects it, creating this
shape. Here's another cone that has a plane cutting straight across through it.
And notice that this plane is horizontal to the base of the cone. For this
shape, we have a plane cutting at an angle down to the side of the cone. And,
finally, for this shape, We have a plane cutting through a double cone. So what
I want you to do is match each of these conic sections with the picture that is
represented by it. So if you think this shape is a circle, you would write a in
this box. Good luck here.